Kylie who do you play in the film that
would be such a great bathroom nose but
I have so many questions about the
outfits that's what I'd be interested in
cuz I loved your efforts obviously well
thanks oh now cuz my new outfit I either
look like a fashionable gas station
attendant and then I I have a long big a
big dress and I have a hairstyle where I
look it looks like a baboon's ass like
in a really good way of course it's a
very good way and Daisy you get to use
your lovely English voice I do
throughout I do it John not so much
no I have an American accent to it he's
so good oh it's in credit your accent is
so good
I think yeah I mean I tried it in the
British but it didn't work out I'm a
stormtrooper man say yeah yes yes I'm
Jake they were just like uh John I don't
think it's right let's go with America
but what if you hadn't been able to do
America then I would have been pissed
because Carrie way back in the beginning
19 was it 76 76 36 when you're on set
your first day on set you would a
similar thing with an accent but mine
was an accident
accent if I had it's viral I've been
going to school here it's the Central
School of Speech and Drama oh yes and
we've been taught to sort of say what to
do to tie today to mean it's a truth to
to a thing distinctly hard to say but
harder thing to do and so beautiful you
can see it in all my work
the levels and the layers so um I win it
was like governor talking I thought I
recognized your foul stench when I
arrived on board now I did't
conversationally and George came to me
the only time I really got direction
from George was the first day he said
you are really upset you're just about
to have your planet blown up and you
know such like and when I get upset I
become British it you do better at
conflict than we are and so I'm just
dead so try to stop governor talking I
thought I recognized your foul stench
where I ride on ball
comments you know oh yeah whatever blood
one of the blah blah blah get down to
this one mr. David Beckham
that's my jumper I just wanted to meet
you make